Newsweek published the fact check did
New Zealand's just send to ardern call
to censor Free Speech yes no no thank
you Newsweek for for correcting the
record it's false she didn't actually
call for censoring free speech I was
worried you know because this idea that
a world leader would be like we should
control the flow of information really
scared me but thank you Newsweek for
correcting the record and letting us all
know what really happened yeah let me
let me play the video just to make sure
everybody understands we're booting it
up here we got Twitter loading up here
we go we launched an initiative
alongside companies and non-profits to
help improve research and understanding
of how a person's online experiences are
curated by automated processes that's
not so bad right this will also be
important in understanding more about
Miss and disinformation online the
challenge that we must As Leaders
address
sadly I think it's easy to dismiss this
problem as one in the margins I can
certainly understand the desire to leave
it to someone else
As Leaders we're rightly concerned that
even the most light touch approaches to
disinformation could be misinterpreted
as being hostile to the values of free
speech that we value so highly see she
says we value Free Speech why is
everybody Reagan on this
picture today what the answer is to this
challenge I can say with complete
certainty that we cannot ignore it
to do so poses an equal threat to the
Norms we all value Norms after all how
do you successfully end a war
if people are led to believe the reason
for its existence is not only legal but
Noble no hold on there a minute I I
agree with that we were lied into the
Iraq War and when you tried coming out
and saying this was bunk and bunk BS we
shouldn't be there we're Afghanistan for
that matter nobody believed you and the
media kept lying about it well wait a
minute that's the corporate press that
did that that's the government whoa yeah
that was that was former National
Security so uh what does she say how do
you tackle climate change if people do
not believe it exists
think about that here is a to get
serious like this is a despotic speech
this is the the prime minister of New
Zealand saying if people don't believe
something exists you can't manipulate it
it's just remarkable because it's like
imagine going around as a government
leader insisting that we should take
action to stop the moon men from
invading Earth and you're like but why
doesn't anyone believe me when I tell
them the moon men are coming maybe
you're wrong maybe that's the insane
thing about it that right there is the
most important part of the speech it
shows you where these world leaders want
us to be
climate change is ideological now we can
talk about the science behind it that's
fine but there's a rift in politics as
to whether or not people think it is or
isn't happening we just had a video the
other day where Don Lemon tried pushing
a NOAA scientist into saying the
hurricane was was intensified by climate
change and he would not do it that's the
perfect example of what I'm saying I
think there there's climate change
issues I do but I certainly think when
Don Lemon as a zealot is like how is
climate gen affect affecting this and he
goes it's not and he goes well hold on
there a minute like I lived I grew up
there but I think it is I think it is
yeah okay you're a zealot she's clearly
asserting here that she has an ideology
that she wants to persist and there is
an opposition to that ideology she does
not want to exist this is the underlying
message of what this psychopath is
saying we must address this issue yeah
the issue is they want to control what
you can think what you can hear and what
you can see and ultimately how you'll
end up voting because of it yeah the
speech gets worse as it goes on she
pretty much eludes that freedom of
speech is a weapon of War yeah she says
that dissenting voices are evil and
dangerous to her how do you ensure that
you the human rights of others are
upheld when they are subject to hateful
and dangerous rhetoric and ideology okay
that's not disinformation or
misinformation though that's opinion but
let's
the weapons may be different
but the goals of those who perpetuate
them is often the same
to cause chaos and reduce the ability of
others to defend themselves
to disband communities
to collapse the Collective Strength of
countries who work together
but we have an opportunity here to
ensure that these particular weapons of
war do not become an established part of
warfare weapons
it gets worse she's calling for a global
censorship effort is she saying that
people who can often happens to feel
facing many battles on many fronts
but there is cause for optimism
because for every new weapon we face
there is a new tool to overcome it
for every attempt to push the world into
chaos is a collective conviction to
bring us back good news we have the
means
we just need the collective will global
censorship effort this is the end game
that they're working on that they're
pushing for he or she is a globalist
world economic Forum Lackey and stewed
she has secret meetings with BlackRock
she locked down her entire country and
punished people for for political causes
during a national quote Health Emergency
when a few cases popped up she locked
down and destroyed people's livelihoods
just a few months ago and we cannot
forget that right now well the whole
Beach is dangerous and it shows us where
we're going Newsweek says fake news Luke
Newsweek says you're wrong and I know I
just listened to what she said
but I see a little meter with a needle
pointing to the red ones
that's all you need can I take can I
take this home for just a second in fact
so I'm I'm in Oklahoma nobody nobody
looks at Oklahoma we got you know we got
two college football teams and that's
what people think of but the the
president of the University of Oklahoma
gave very much this same speech about
inclusive free speech at the University
of Oklahoma of saying that you know we
can't have free speech unless everybody
feels the same and thinks the same and
says the same things yeah and and so
that it's coming from the ground up and
from the top down and that's what we
have to start realizing and that's why I
really want people who are you know like
me out there in the trenches in these
states that maybe nobody pays attention
to looking for this in their local media
looking for this in their in their
colleges and in their schools because
it's it's not just coming from leaders
of New Zealand or even the United States
it's coming from your local leaders from
your University leaders your school
leaders and and Your Business Leaders
even if even at a point well this is the
gas lighting that that's happening here
like you saw what you said uh it's
totally fake news don't worry just trust
us again this is the orwellian this is
1984. this is this is what they're
essentially after because if they can
control information they know that they
control people's minds and the only
thing standing in the way of them
subjugating and controlling everyone is
people just being able to talk freely
with each other that is the biggest
threat against their entire Ponzi scheme
which is their governments and this is
not just the local government of New
Zealand they are working together on a
global effort with many leaders many
prime ministers many presidents many
people behind the scenes who are really
controlling them saying hey we're going
to push this slowly and surely and the
end goal of what she's calling for here
is a global censorship board that's
internationally everywhere applied to
everyone on the face of this Earth I
want you to imagine a scenario
you're sitting down with uh someone
and uh pop on Twitter pops up this video
where Joe Biden says so I told him it's
uh sick what time is it six o'clock if
if everyone always like those times if
if the prosecutor's not fired by six
o'clock you're not getting the money
and well SOB guy gets fired and then you
sitting there
you say whoa did Joe Biden just quit pro
quo and the man next to you wearing the
suit says
Russia put that video out oh and then I
want you to imagine what like level of
cognitive ability you would have to have
to go oh
oh that that proves it this is just
phase one they're weeding out the people
that'll just believe the gaslighting
next it's going to be deep fakes where
even the intelligent people don't know
what's real well well already if we say
that this happened the fact Checkers are
going to demote downrank our posts
delete our post delete our entire
accounts and our ability to even have a
voice on the internet and might even go
as far as to destroy our ability to earn
money which is centrally linked to of
course online centralized platforms like
like PayPal that legitimately do punish
people because of their political
opinions I want you to just imagine or
actually no there's a meme it's really
funny it's two people sitting down in a
post-apocalyptic world and he hands a
meme to the other guy and it's like you
know the meme exists well it's already
there I don't know if I'm saying there's
a meme of it yeah it's like he's got a
physical meme he's got to hand to
somebody else but I want to hit on
something you brought up because it
takes an actual process to get the mind
to do what you explain to have that guy
in the suit the expert tell you that to
not believe what you see with your eyes
that's social emotional learning yeah
that's exactly what that is because you
train kids and you train people over a
course of time there are multitudes of
different ways even through the media
that you that you consume right and they
train you to respond emotionally because
you then feel wait a minute am I
offending this person then I better
agree with him and then agreeing with
him means it's altered my reality that's
social emotional learning and that's
what's happening in your schools right
now that's that's the whether you're
talking about anti-racism or you're
talking about diversity equity and
inclusion they all mean pretty much the
exact opposite of what they're saying
but they play upon the emotions to make
you feel a different way the end result
is go is that Liberals are are killing
their own kids and sterilizing them so
it's like
with the future if they if they get
control of the information systems I'm
still not convinced that
they will perpetuate their ideology
enough yeah I don't know I'm terrified
that that could happen like being kids
people being born into a system where
they don't where they're just being told
it'll be what will happen is the things
we know now can be erased from the
conscious memory they can be Rewritten
the digit of all the things can be
burned this stuff can be trans like we
probably were born into a system of
brainwashing without realizing it sure
oh Columbus sailed the ocean blue we're
the good guys and then you find out the
eradication of the genocide of the
population the all the horrors or is
that even real yeah exactly who knows
what who knows what is real you may be
no this is an important point just to
hit on that when you're like we hear
that Columbus did you know he came here
and discovered America or whatever
that's like oh okay that's really cool
then you learn later like actually he
genocided the Native Americans the
question is which which version of
history is the true version if one of
them is wrong how do you know which
one's the real one if either of them are
real right right probably no Christopher
Columbus came over on a jet ski and like
just chill I grew up in the United
States just fine and if I was if I was
in some sort of fog intentional up you
know be made to believe lies and stuff I
was okay about it and I was totally
happy so I'm afraid that people could
grow up in this modern technocratic
society and experience the same kind of
thing just go along with a you know Free
Speech not knowing what that means or
they'll still use the term Free Speech
but it will mean what they want it to be
redefined as the freedoms you sacrifice
now your children will never know or
practice it uh that's a it's a famous
quote I butchered it it doesn't matter
but what Jacinda over here this this
lunatic crazy insane bureaucrat from New
Zealand is calling for is already
happening in other parts of the world in
the United Kingdom if you offend someone
with your post and someone sees it you
go to Jail recently a UK police officer
arrested someone because he called them
a wiener head uh but in a more unfamily
unfamily family show that's rough oh in
a more
okay the censorship boards are already
uh I have to navigate it carefully here
but if we need to say like Express like
yes you know the algorithm also picks up
harsh language as well
but he has you know buddies and he he
repeats the and he gets demonetized
support you Phil so so so so again I I
also want to be respectful to the
children out there and their families
out there but it's also a name but but
just to bring it back here what Jacinda
is calling for is already happening
she's just calling for it to be
implemented everywhere under the control
of one centralized body that will get to
arrest people for offending people
hurting their emotions and saying things
that the government
arbitrarily says well this is not
accepted now you go to jail she says
that people some the people will use
this tactic of putting knowledge out
that's fake basically lying and that
often they have do it for the reasons of
destroying an evil but she's very clear
that it's often it's not all the time
that's why you're innocent until proven
guilty if if you put out you can lie
you're like you're allowed to lie and
insult people at least in this country
you are thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there